ladies and gentlemen I Margo Williamson
returning officer for the Angus
constituency declare the total number of
votes given to each candidate was as
follows william bishop gumbo 5233
Kirsten Jeanette here Scottish
Conservative new news party
18100 48 Clive Roderick Sneden Scottish
Liberal Democrats 1308 Michael freezer
we are Scottish Nationalist Party
15500 M
therefore I give public notice that kiss
customer is duly elected to serve as a
member of parliament bianca constituency
thank you thank you to the returning
officer the presiding officer the police
and the absolute per host team of staff
that we have here tonight I know that it
was a difficult job falling on from the
hectic local elections on to the general
election but you have carried this out
with the greatest of efficiency as you
always do thank you to my campaign team
who were there with me every minute of
the past five very hectic weeks I
couldn't have asked for a better support
team and I am so incredibly grateful for
everything that you have done for me I
know I was a hard taskmaster at times
but you came with me every step of the
way thank you to my family to my parents
to Jim and Alison to my sister's Louise
and Deborah and my brother James as my
family and my extended family you
couldn't have been a better support base
I couldn't have asked for anyone better
to be around me but most of all my
thanks goes to all those that have put
their faith in me this evening many of
those won't be natural conservative
voters there will be people that haven't
voted for us in a long time or they're
voting for us for the first time and
they voted for me because we vote but we
essentially campaigned on two platforms
we campaigned for change here in I guess
for a strong local hard-working
candidate somebody that was visible in
the constituency and hardworking in
Westminster but fundamentally the big
issue in Scotland is the question over
independence and the constitutional
debate of which people have so loudly
and clearly stated that they want taken
off the table they want that uncertainty
taken away from our country and run
and for us to focus on the issues that
really matter to the people of Scotland
I will be a strong local voice for
everybody that has voted for me in this
constituency and everybody that didn't
align with me in this campaign I will be
a public servant not a party servant I
am under I am under no illusion that the
hard work starts now but I will with the
greatest honor and integrity represent
the people of Angus as your Member of
Parliament in Westminister
with Minister it would be the greatest
honor of my life and I cannot wait to
get started thank you
[Applause]